so running asp.net core apps without a
server what my name is Isaac Levin
um
maybe I should turn my clicker on my
name is Isaac Levin if you have not uh
heard of me maybe you've seen some other
talks from me maybe you've seen me on
Twitter maybe you've seen me on all
sorts of different Tech social media
because I love the look of my face and I
love the sound of my voice so I'm
everywhere
um here if you do not know about me you
can follow me some of the places here I
also have a podcast called coffee and
open source where I interview folks all
across the tech landscape of interview
folks like Scott Hanselman uh Kelsey
Hightower Martin Woodward works at
GitHub
um a lot of actually folks and speakers
that are here at NDC have interviewed
them in the past
um so if you like Tech podcasts and
people ranting about tech give that a
shot
um I appreciate it so let's get to the
topic at hand
how did we used to build web apps like
not web apps today like in the past
like what are some of the ways that
folks you folks here have built web apps
just shout them out we're all friendly
right
oh you're gonna you're not gonna give me
anything are you all right well I'm
gonna do the work for you then I guess
so the web forms era
so who here knows about web forms
all right
does anybody know show of hands are not
sure of hands just shout it out like
what the architecture for
web form says
terrible
there's a particular model for it that
model is called page controller so let's
talk a little bit about the web forms
there at the time so the time was around
2002 VB6 was
slowly slowly slowly dying Wind forms is
the way that people were building
applications for the desktop when forms
is awesome because you could drag things
from Visual Studio designer onto a
designer canvas and you could create
client uis
really quickly into the studio awesome
experience
and then the decision becomes we should
have a similar thing but for the web
right so
Microsoft started to build out what they
now call what was called the time web
forms a page controller model which
basically what that means that you have
a UI and you have a code behind
so you have an aspx and you have an asmx
right
so what's really important to call about
the web forms era is that web forms from
a developer's perspective was really
really good right you could drop things
in you can drop things into your pane
you can really have a fast experience
developing locally however what's one of
the big drawbacks for web forms
performance
view state if you say it's back by the
way uh what else
yeah a lot of stuff was kind of hidden
from us as developers right like you
drag control like a text box control
into your aspx file and then like all
this HTML would just get generated for
you great experience also not that great
of experience if you need to like make
any modifications to what that HTML
actually gets rendered like right so
what ends up happening over the course
of that that six years or so web forms
continues to evolve continues to evolve
but it still has these problems that how
do we fix the experience because
remember at this point in time like the
web is still fairly new right the idea
of building apps on the web is fairly
new and the idea that like do customers
like end users they really care like
what the page looks like
like do they really care not really
right there's not a lot of things out
there to make the experience better
but then what happens right after this
era
anyone take a hint
MVC we're gonna get there
focus on accessibility
there's a phrase that's used in the
industry a lot that defines the next era
who here has heard of Web 2.0 or at
least heard the phrase don't really know
what it means but like I I need a Web
2.0 app web2o 2.0 basically means
like Rich client experiences client
being end user so like the web page
looks nice HTML CSS and JavaScript start
to grow aggressively and people are
trying to build really really
interesting things including some of
these things here I don't know what
generation you all are from I graduated
high school or I don't know I don't know
what it's called in Norway if it's
called if it's not called high school
and like Myspace was like a really
really big deal
and building Myspace Pages was an
amazing experience because you could
like put your own HTML CSS and
JavaScript like into your my estate's
profile and it would render on the page
just like a great idea from a platform
perspective like let's just run random
JavaScript in the browser and see what
happens right but there was like there
were like you had like this feeling of
real success if you like your Myspace
profile could like crash someone's
browser right like just playing copious
amounts of weird music flashing lights
all sorts of crazy stuff and that is
basically like the Web 2.0 experience
using JavaScript HTML and CSS to really
customize your end user's experience and
like most of the
um companies are are platforms that you
see on this slide here
are very much still alive today but were
founded during the Web 2.0 time
right
so how does Microsoft and how's the.net
team react to 2.0
any guesses
Silverlight not yet but yes
they say let's make JavaScript more
accessible inside of web forms
they use the Ajax control toolkit they
use the ability to bring Jake they
started shipping jQuery in projects like
in the project templates right who
remembers jQuery who still uses jQuery
still the best way to write JavaScript
apps by the way
after that
there is a paradigm shift
there were
different ways to build apps after Web
2.0 most notably like you can build apps
completely in JavaScript Spa apps
Frameworks started to come out that were
built on JavaScript
and one of the models from an
architecture standpoint that came out
during that time was the model view
controller model which as we all know is
MVC so Microsoft starts to build
a model view controller
platform on top of.net and that's called
MVC now around 2008 and that that whole
evolution is up until about 2014. and
what's great about MVC
is that something else came along with
MVC for the ride that we really don't
think about it just happened to be there
and now we take advantage of it even
still to this day and you know what that
is
so so what does the C stand for in MVC
controllers right what are controllers
technically
apis
web API comes along with MVC in a little
bit after I think it's like version
three of MVC
and then we have this experience where
we can actually like build apis and
applications that have an actual UI in
the same way
like that's an amazing experience for a
developer right like the idea of like oh
I build code runs once and it runs in a
bunch of different states right really
cool
and one of the great things too about
MVC is that we start to see a shift from
XML from as a from a web service
perspective
to Json
all the JavaScript Frameworks they use
Json to pass data and MVC starts to
allow that as well
what's really interesting is that
when you think about MVC it's still used
today right like job a large option
Frameworks will use MVC obviously you
can use you can use MVC to build
modern.net apps
but what's interesting for the most in
my opinion with MVC is that it was the
first real attempt by Microsoft to build
components and build Platforms in the
open
right who here remembers code Plex
code Plex was like GitHub before it was
cool right
um
so Microsoft made a concerted effort to
start to ship this code in a public
forum so people can actually view it
and that's started and it continues to
evolve today when you see modern.net
it's all on GitHub and things like that
we'll talk about that in a second
but
the most interesting thing to me with
MVC is that if you're still building
like you need that Web 2.0 experience
like you can still take advantage of
jQuery you can still take advantage of
JavaScript and all of that and we start
to see those experiences coming into
Visual Studio proper so what happens
after 2014 what happens in 2014 that
like really is a catalyst in this in the
entire web space
react
node.js npm
JavaScript
JavaScript Frameworks mean applications
and then people realize like MVC kind of
stinks to build web apps
because I want to be able to build like
really rich web experiences with
cascading drop downs and cool animations
and MVC can't do that because I have to
post back to the server
right because remember that like all of
these different Frameworks web forms MVC
they all require some sort of
interaction with the server they have to
post back and the in the server has to
send some HTML back or a request back
response back sorry
so like JavaScript wins right
like around 2014 2015 like who was a
developer around that time
JavaScript one right like there's a
point in time where it's like oh do we
all need to be like Knockout JS
developers I don't know if knockout was
around at that time do we all need to be
like angularjs developers no instead
I've done it we use.net for apis we
definitely don't bring build front ends
without net anymore that's like what
like Grandpa did
so what happens next right
so 2014 happens
Microsoft's used the writing on the wall
they say hey
like a lot of these web applications
that are being built today they're being
built on non-windows devices they're
being built and deployed to non-windows
platforms they're running on Mac they're
running on Linux devices right
that along with a lot of other things
Microsoft starts to build what they call
v-next of.net and asp.net that
eventually turns into something called
asp.net core and who you hear use
asp.net core today
it's the best thing ever right
that's right so that's 2014
uh so the 1.0 version shipped a couple
years later the 1.1 version shipped and
then a couple years after that uh two
Auto shipped I was at build when they
shipped 2.0 and I think it was kind of
like the okay this is ready like the the
bits haven't shifted the bits aren't
shifting anymore really and you can
start building apps in this framework in
this particular way and be successful
and I think it was the first
you know other than adding like a jQuery
um like JavaScript include in your
projects it was like the first time that
like Microsoft starts to embrace these
JavaScript Frameworks like Spa templates
are available like out of the box like
you can create an angular app that hits
an asp.net core backend and like you
don't need to wire all that up it comes
for you in the template
right one of the things that's also
really really great about asp.net core
is it because of the fact that it's no
longer tied to Windows and IIs it start
it ships with its own web server
that web server is called Kessel and why
is that interesting
and because it gives you flexibility to
do things like create proxies manage the
info manage the instances of your web
services in a particular way that's
really valuable to you right all at the
end of the day
this allows you to be more flexible as a
developer because you can build on an
Acer platform deploy to any sort of
platform in your heart's content
right
so that's to today
however there's still one problem with
asp.net core like MVC or Razer pages and
what's that problem
but what if I still want Web 2.0
you promised me Web 2.0 like 10 years
ago
and now you're telling me like hey you
now you have a cross-platform version
of.net but it's still not Web 2.0 like
it doesn't give me Rich JavaScript
experiences out of the box it doesn't
give me uh
the the ability to not have to post back
like what if I want Web 2.0 well at that
particular time you had two options
you could
use just plain old JavaScript or jQuery
put that in your project and you could
go about your Merry way jQuery show the
best way to build uh front end apps in
my opinion
or you can go the second approach and
what's the second approach
Razer
so Razer is still server side rendered
right so Razer is still
um like a like a a Razer file or a chtml
file it for using razor Pages or MVC
like it still requires a postback you
can put some tricky JavaScript in there
to make it not seem like it but it still
does post back
but if you want true Web 2.0 at this
particular time
you get to Choose Your Own Adventure
right who here knows what all of those
logos are
not one person all right class we're
going to do it one by one all right
what's the what's the green V
yay what about the blue and black thing
we're skipping that one what about the
red a
angular what about the black n next JS
what about the s
svelte what about the thing that says
Ember
and what about the last one react so
what's this one
I said it already Knockout JS
not go JS is interesting because it was
built by somebody named Steve Sanders
we'll talk about that individual in a
second
so if you still want like Web 2.0
experience you still got to use
JavaScript right you still gotta like
be in this constant state of hopping
between
server-side rendered Solutions or by
building apis in.net and then happen to
like open up something else because the
visual studio tooling at the time was
um opportunistic let's say that you have
to spin up like you know Sublime Text or
maybe you know in the last few years
like vs code and then you build like
your front end and then you run both at
the same time because everybody's got 64
gigs of RAM
and you're happy to an extent right but
you could be happier and I think you
know where this is going right
what if you didn't need JavaScript
I'm gonna play a video funny enough
this video happened at NDC Oslo
about five years ago I think it's 2017.
20 uh 20 2017 2018. was anybody here
yeah were you was your mind blown yeah
is anybody everybody here seen this
video I'm gonna show like two or three
minutes of this video so bear with me
I just realized that I probably need to
plug in audio
I need to plug in audio as am I going to
just plug this in okay
and if it works and I don't blow out the
TV awesome
now if any of you were in my talk
yesterday you may find this to look
quite similar quite familiar because it
looks the same as the angular and react
and other templates that we've got
shipping at the moment and it's got the
same functionality as those do so we've
got basic client-side navigation I can
go backwards and forwards we've got an
example of a component that lets you
increment a count and an example of
fetching some data from the back end
there
but what does this code really look like
then so let's expand all this stuff and
we will see that it is not reactor or
angular or anything like that and in
fact there's no JavaScript in here
whatsoever none it is just C sharp and
razor and what does it really look like
well let's have a look at this counter
code here and it's very very simple and
predictable okay I'm using C sharp to
say I'm going to have a count property
which is an INT and then I've got a
method that when you click when you call
it it's going to increment that count
I'm using Razer to display the current
count and I've got a button that you can
click and it will increment the count in
that kind of way so that is how that
works and other nice things work too for
example if I want to change my code
let's change that to counter one two
three it's just going to update very
quickly and if I wanted to make it go up
in tens rather than ones then I come
back and click that and it will do okay
so it's compiling very quickly there and
it does that by having an instance of
the Rosalind compiler in memory there so
so not inside the browser but in on the
server there we've got a Roslyn compiler
that can very quickly produce updated
dlls that can get loaded and run through
webassembly there so that's very nice
and fast
but would it really be nice for you as a
developer to build something like this
what would the actual experience be like
let's have a go at adding a bit of
functionality to this site now and I'll
do the classic example that everybody
always wants to do which is of course a
to-do list so I'm going to create so
we're not going to watch the entire
video because you paid to not watch a
Youtube video
um basically what Steve Steve Sanderson
who was the person who created
knockout.js and eventually created
this particular experiment which turns
into something
that most of us have probably heard of
at least based on hand raising earlier
he talked about a particular promise
and that particular promise is the idea
of using c-sharp to build Web 2.0
experience applications and you don't
need any JavaScript if you want
JavaScript you can you still use
JavaScript it's not replacing JavaScript
but it's giving the ability to build
apps only in c-sharp without having to
worry about server side and all of that
sort of stuff right so
coincidentally enough that particular
project was an experiment at the time it
was using something
um called uh I can't remember exactly
what it was called but it was a minified
version of.net that basically would was
able to run in the browser I think it
was.net anywhere if I'm wrong somebody
in the YouTube comments in the future
will say that was wrong
however
let's move along
so how is this actually able to be
accomplished so who you heard of wasm or
webassembly
who here can like give me a pretty
accurate description of what it is
okay
so there was like
40 people raising their hand for I I've
heard of it but one person who can
describe it
um
so webassembly and I'm going to
oversimplify it so I apologize
it's a bright it's a binary instruction
format that allows you to build and
compile applications that are written in
miscellaneous languages down to a
particular format that can be ran by the
browser that's all it really is so
whether you're Building C plus plus or
rust or C sharp or
go or what have you more than likely
there's a compiler in most cases that
will allow you to take that programming
language that compiled code that you
have and run it in a browser
and that's what webassembly does and
webassembly ship 1.0 shipped a handful
of years ago and it supported in all the
major browsers that's great why are we
talking about webassembly when we were
talking about.net earlier you probably
know where this is going
how do we use.net with webassembly well
the answer is Blazer
so just a little bit of backstory on
Blazer so
when
that experiment the idea it was called
Blazer initially and
the experiment evolved in a handful of
ways the first iteration of Blazer was
what we call Blazer server which
coincidentally enough is the same
development experience but the way that
you get information from the server to
the UI was using like a websocket client
or signalr client to send the diff of a
Dom back and forth
so kind of tricking you into thinking
that it's like running in the browser
because there's no postbacks or there's
no anything but it's still making calls
back out to the server
and then there was
an implementation of blazer for
webassembly called Blazer wasm
and that uses the mono run time to
basically compile your c-sharp
application
into a into a particular format that
runs in the browser and there are some
positives to that right like you can run
this in very small environments right
like that like you don't need a server
so you can run them in places that you
would not expect them to be able to run
you have access to the full.net runtime
so you have access to all the great
things that we're used to as we build on
developers and there's a simple
architecture in the grand scheme of
things because you don't have to rely on
some web server technology running on
your particular systems but there are
drawbacks right
for instance bless you
for instance you can't have an
experience that's offline
right because you need to have some
interaction with some server
or else it's not going to work there's
also latency there's also size of the
project because you're loading the.net
runtime into your app right into the
browser
and there's server resources that do
come along that because you're going to
eventually have to make some service
calls
but these are similar cons that you
would get if you were to build any spy
app today using react or view or what
have you the the trade-off is that it's
all in c-sharp
and if you want to sprinkle some
JavaScript on there you definitely can
but you don't have to
so why would I do this like why would I
like use some new technology somebody
mentioned Silverlight earlier like
hasn't this already been done before
um why would you use this new thing
instead of just using something some Web
2.0 experience or web 2.4 America that's
been around for 10 years the reason
is quite simple
you get access to all the new language
features of C sharp so there was a talk
I think yesterday about all the cool
things that are in C sharp if you didn't
see that please watch it because there's
some really cool things that have been
the last like two or three versions of C
sharp that you probably didn't know
about
you also have access to the entire.net
ecosystem which means
all of the rich experiences have been
built out in the community third party
libraries all those sort of things right
you might not have that same coverage if
you were to look out in different
JavaScript Frameworks
you also get amazing performance
like if you if you pay attention to
anything from the.net team in the last
five years
they immediately say performance
at 10x faster 12x faster than node
whatever whatever the numbers are today
performance is very very important for
the.net team right because they
understand that in order to quote
unquote be relevant in the web space
they have to be more performant than all
these JavaScript Solutions otherwise
people will use those JavaScript
Solutions
you have the experience to build
applications quote unquote full stack
and I hate whenever we put the word full
in front of everything or like you know
full stack developer like that's not a
thing that's just somebody that doesn't
know what they're doing in three layers
um but you do have the ability to like
build your apis as well as build your
clients in the same solution using the
same programming language which is
really valuable right
tools like there are some really great
tools to build.net apps right jetbrains
is out here talking about writer
writer's awesome visual studio is
awesome vs code is getting really really
good to build.net apps on so you have in
my opinion like the best tool chain to
build apps for the web
with those tools
and then finally you have access to 20
plus years
of a company knowing how to build apps
for the web right
don't disregard that experience like
some think mature or stable those are
like not okay things
I definitely would rather go down the
path if I'm building an app today I'd
rather build something stable and mature
than something that's like the new
hotness
like I showed a bunch of the new hotness
right and some of you didn't even like
Knockouts like the oldest one and you
don't even know what it was
um
so these are some of the reasons why
it's advantageous to use Blazer
but what actually comes for the ride
when you use Blazer these are some of
the things you get I'm not going to go
over every single one of them because
obviously you folks can read
the biggest things to me
are things like aot compilation so the
mono runtime allows you to use ahead of
time compilation and to oversimplify it
it basically allows you to have very
very very small application packages
right very very performant there are
some limitations today with aot
compilation
but the.net team is putting a lot of
effort into making sure that those are
very minimal like one big thing is like
if you want to build an app today and
you want to be aot compology change
reflection
so if use reflection today you need to
use something like Source generators or
some other mechanism to be able to use
get that same sort of functionality so
if you're building apps today they use
lots of reflection aot might not be an
option for you
another thing that's really really great
is hot reload so like I think we've all
seen demos of how to reload like I'm you
know my app is I'm currently debugging
my app it's running in Visual Studio I
make some changes to it and then I hit a
button and I don't have to rebuild
recompile my app just like changes
right like that's an amazing experience
and that's one of the things that you
get out of the box of Blazer
also the ability to have like really
rich interop between JavaScript like
c-sharp classes calling into JavaScript
firing JavaScript functions JavaScript
functions calling in the c-sharp product
like the interoper ability is really
really valuable because in the situation
where we do need JavaScript we want to
make sure that it's secure
right
so the ability to have those Rich
experiences is really really valuable
so the question then becomes all right
Isaac the name of your talk is like
running asp.net core apps without a
server what
um so what are some of the options
imagine most of you folks have probably
seen like some other sessions that talk
about this directly but let's talk about
some other options other than like
static web apps because I think that's
the one that a lot of people think of
immediately
what about Azure storage
like who here isn't like uses Azure in
their day-to-day
all right who here uses like Azure blob
storage in their day-to-day
all right who here knew that you can
like host Blazer apps in static webs in
static storage today
all right less people as I went forward
that's good means that people are
learning something new so basically how
it works is you can take your Blazer app
your Blazer wasm project you can publish
it and then you can take those published
bits which are static files so HTML CSS
JavaScript and some dlls
you can take the that publish folder and
you can put it
in Azure blob storage and then you make
some small configurations Azure blob
storage humiliate your website you have
a website running in Azure blob storage
so that's really really awesome
and let's actually take a look at what
that looks like so I am in
open this up
I am in a command line and the folks in
the back can see this okay
all right so I'm going to dot net new a
Blazer wasm project and I'm just going
to call this NDC
so basically what I'm going to what this
is this is like the template for a
Blazer web assembly project it's nothing
special we can take a look at what it
looks like after it
restores all the packages so let's go in
here NDC and then I'm just going to open
up code insiders and then I'm going to
dot net run this
so basically what I'm doing here is I'm
just running the application so the
application it's going to look like if
you've built a.net app in the last like
four years it's going to look like the
one that you've all seen but one thing
that's really important to call out is
that it's all everything runs in the
browser so
this is the app as you can see here
there's a counter this is very similar
to a Steve Sanderson showed a while ago
but there's a counter and there's no
postbacks going on here and there's
flipping between the routes but if I
take a look
let's go over to vs code real quick if I
take a look at the project and I look at
the bin directory I have a WWE root and
I have some dlls however let's stop this
and let's just do.net
publish
and let's just set the configuration to
release
and then let's set the output to publish
so all I'm doing here is I'm just
publishing this Blazer webassembly
project to a you know basically to a
state where I can deploy it to other
environments and if I take a look at
that after it's done which it does take
a little bit of time
let's open up this property file
it's done all right so let's take a look
here so this is our
WWE root so inside of here we have a CSS
file we have HTML you can log I can zoom
in a little bit here we have a framework
we have CSS let's take a look at what's
in the framework folder
so I'm not going to scroll the way down
but as you can see there's some dlls and
there's like this.net wasm which is the
uh.net runtime for wasm and then there's
the a couple of JS files
blazer.webassembly.js and that's the
magic so the blazer.webassembly.js
basically takes
your.net.wasm and your other
files for your application and basically
transpiles it into bytecode that it can
run webassembly
so that's the that's the quote-unquote
magic of it so if you were to go home
today and you were to create a new
blazer webassembly project and you were
to do this thing and you want to play
around you want to see like what some of
these things did like for instance if I
opened up this Json file here
like obviously you can't read it but it
and you can actually take a look at the
GitHub repo for it because it's all
available and free on GitHub you can see
what's actually going on here but the
long and short of it
is that this does all the work to get
your apps to a state where you can run
them in places where you don't need a
server so the question then becomes okay
so how do I go to Azure static web apps
so I'm in the Azure portal
and I'm using Dark theme because
somebody told me that light theme sucks
um what I want to be able to do is I
want to take this Blazers this uh sorry
this Azure storage account and I want to
make it host my Azure stack site so if I
scroll down in the data management
section
right here oops
there's a static website section and if
I click on that
it's going to walk me through a really
quick experience to basically do just
that I can enable static websites and I
can specify the document so in this
particular case I'm just going to have
it be index.html for both and I put a
slash in there I didn't need to
so and then after that I save
and then what's going to do is it's
actually going to create a container in
my Azure storage account which is
optimized and configured for that static
site and then I have a primary endpoint
a secondary endpoint so if I go up to
foreign if I go up to storage browser
and take a look at my blob containers
now I now have one for web
and I can then upload
all of that stuff let's just go here
Dev demos NDC publish
WWE root all of this stuff and I can
drag and drop this
directly in here oops not like that
Isaac you idiot
right in here
I am failing miserably hold on open this
do this drag this here all right and
then it's going to take all those 126
files and it's going to upload them to
that container
and once that's done after short after a
very very quick amount of time after I
click upload here it will actually allow
me to go to that endpoint that I
specified earlier once this is done
these are all cued
do do make sure they're all actually
uploaded
I think this gives you an up here at the
top they're successfully uploaded so
then I go back down to that static
website section and I can open up this
primary endpoint here
so I open that up
and then
hopefully
ta-da
we have a blade we have a net
application running in Azure blob
storage and then to take this one step
further I can put this in front of a CDN
and again all that great experience from
a CDN caching all that great stuff the
question then becomes okay this is cool
but like like you need a web server
right you can configure this to hit an
Azure function or you can configure it
to hit you know any web service external
API that you have
um you know
the the interesting thing about doing it
for this particular way is that Azure
storage in the grand scheme of things is
very very inexpensive so if you have an
application that doesn't need like a lot
of computing
an option to host an Azure storage is
very very interesting
all right did you know you can do that
you learned something today
congratulations
all right
moving on
the next one is definitely more
interesting
so who here like has ever played around
with like GitHub pages
for the folks aren't raising your hand
like I highly recommend using it because
it's free
like there's not very many places that
you can get like free web hosting right
even though it's static but you can
actually take a blizzard webassembly
project and run them in GitHub pages
and how you do that there's a few ways
you can do it but the the way that I
think is the is the most stable from a
workflow perspective is using GitHub
actions
and I assume there's some talks here on
GitHub actions at NDC if you want to
learn more about them check those out
but basically what GitHub actions allows
you to do is it allows you to configure
CI CD
for GitHub pages
so basically you have a yamla file that
defines your GitHub workflow actions
workflow and inside of there we'll take
a look at what it looks like it
configures the build the publish and the
the configuration needed to set up
GitHub pages and all that's done for you
so let's actually take a look at what
that looks like
hop over to my browser close things that
I'm not paying attention to
all right so here I'm inside a GitHub
project that I created last week
and inside of here if you look I already
have GitHub Pages configured so I can go
over here and I can open this if I
wanted to one of the things that I've
done is I've configured a GitHub action
to actually
build and deploy this Blazer webassembly
project which is the same things I did
earlier like the uh you know Blazer
webassembly project starter template so
nothing super exciting but I configured
it to basically every time I do a commit
it does a build and a publish and then
it published and then stages it out to
GitHub pages
and how I'm doing that
is by using this workflow file that I
have defined here I'm specifying my.net
version which is 8.0 and I'm making sure
the.net quality is preview I'm GLA I'm
glossing over a lot of like the GitHub
action stuff so if you haven't had any
experience with GitHub actions you can
come up to me afterwards we can talk a
little bit about GitHub actions but
basically what I do is i.net publish my
blazer GitHub pages.cs proj
and I specify a release so that's the
configuration for it I also need to do a
couple of things to make it work and
GitHub Pages specifically around
um
making sure that the a 404
redirects sends somewhere so I'm just
basically doing the same thing I did
with Azure storage where okay the 404
just redirects to index
and then I'm also basically remapping
the
um the base of the actual website to be
a particular endpoint because GitHub
Pages routes things differently because
he actually uses like your GitHub
repository as basically the file system
for your actual uh static site and then
I add some configuration for for Jekyll
because because GitHub Pages uses some
Jekyll for that and I specify the folder
for that so the long and short of it
if I go and look at my particular
environment
I see I've done some deployments I click
on a deployment
and then I had that same experience
right and if I wanted to like I had that
same experience if I wanted to I can
actually like use GitHub to make changes
to my project and then when I do a
commit it'll re it'll kick off that
workflow and do all those things so
let's actually do that because why not
so who here sort of like github.dev
github.dev is really really cool because
basically it allows you to like update
and modify like multiple files and
repository without having to do like a
clone and it's free like it's not like
code space or anything like that it's
completely free so what I want to be
able to do
is I'm just going to make a modification
here so instead of hello world I'm just
going to change this to hello NDC Oslo
because I'm boring so as you can see
here it says okay you have some changes
to your index in a Razer file and I'm
just going to have this say updates
if I can spell
and then I'm going to
commit and push those changes so when I
do that command push if I go back to my
Repository
uh get up action got kicked off and
we'll take a look at what that get up
action actually does so we we saw the
definition of it so inside that build
step it's going to walk through all of
those individual steps that I defined
earlier so it's going to do a net public
or build a net publish it's going to
remap
um the uh base for all of our static
files it's going to create an end uh 404
that's copied off of index and all this
does take a second but at the end of the
day it's actually going to deploy it to
GitHub pages and how it deploys to get a
page is it actually creates another
branch in your repository called GH
pages and that is actually the branch
that is used the file structure for
GitHub Pages under the hood so if you
ever use GitHub pages and you're like
well how does this actually work you'll
if you go to your branches you'll see
like oh there's this GH Pages thing that
I didn't create it gets created for you
by default when you configure GitHub
Pages for your Repository
so in this particular case so this is
doing that.net publish hopefully this
does not take too long I'm going to
stall actually let's do this instead of
stalling I'm just going to go back to
the presentation then we can hop back
here
um in a little bit
so that's Blazer webassembly to get up
pages so that's kind of cool right did
you know you could do that
awesome well this guy is really really
good at his job he's like raised his
hand to every single question it's
awesome
so
we took a look at that demo
but there's still a problem
like what if I need like really really
fast iterative developer experiences I
really need fast
um
request response interactivity with the
server
what if I need an interactive design
what if I want Web 2.0 because that's
what people told me 20 years ago was
really important and what if I need the
flexibility to to navigate between the
both
what is the problem with blazer
webassembly let's just call it out
what if I was it to like take like an
e-commerce site or a marketing site and
use Blazer webassembly or any JavaScript
framework and I try to host that what's
going to happen what's the number one
problem
it's not SEO optimized
right meaning that if you look at like
the actual rendered Source when the when
the actual index.html page is loaded
it's like JavaScript and an empty HTML
body
because the JavaScript basically
hydrates all the Dom for you really
really bad for search engine
optimization
so but what is the benefit of some of
the more Legacy Technologies we talked
about web forms MVC razor Pages what's
the benefit of those
it's server side rendered which means
that all of the UI in HTML is passed on
the request from the server to the
client which means that when you right
click inspect and look at the web page
it's the entire HTML great for search
engine optimization for instance
so the question becomes
like what if you need
the server-side rendering experience of
MVC and Razer pages
but you also want
Blazer
you're stuck right you're like oh I got
to go back to like JavaScript
in.net 8
Blazer is now going to ship with
server-side rendering built into it
so you can easily configure or have it
dynamically switched depending on what
situation you're in from server side
rendered to non-server side vendor or
client-side rendered so it's like The
Best of Both Worlds so that's coming
on.net8 if you want to play around with
it I don't have a demo for it
um
the preview 3 of.net8 has this in here
so you can actually go out today and get
a Blazer server application that renders
server side
so really really cool stuff let's go
back to this GitHub oh it's done
so let's check a look and see if our
change actually happened so GitHub pages
two minutes ago view deployment hello
NDC Oslo so it works so you make a
subtle change to your code and then
after that GitHub workflow triggers you
have a site that's updated if anybody's
been doing CI CD they're like okay cool
you just showed me a cicd that's pretty
boring
so the question becomes like what are
the possibilities now
because we can now build completely
c-sharp projects that have Web 2.0
experiences but they're also server side
rendered and you can configure them
based on your environment
and Steve Sanderson has a really good
video I'll be sure to put a link to it
um at the end there's a QR code and I
believe there's a link to like a demo
that already shows like how you can
configure it and what use cases that
make sense right
so that's my talk
I hope that you learned a little bit
something about Blazer webassembly if
you didn't learn about Blazer
webassemblies you enjoyed the history
lesson of.net over the last 20 some odd
years
um if you want to learn more you want to
chat with me about Blazer
webassembly.net in general
um you can find me on Twitter Isaac R11
or some of the other places that I
linked earlier and that's my time I want
to thank you so much for hanging out I
do have limited stickers up here if
that's your jam
um thank you so much for having me it
was a pleasure and I hope you enjoy the
rest of NDC Oslo thank you so much
thank you